many viewers have wanted to get to know
a little bit more about the guy shooting
these these philosophy lecture videos
and so I'm doing more personal talks
about my own background and my views on
things how I arrived at them where I was
before and I think one of the things
that might be interesting to some people
is to hear about what I call my Sartre
in phase which ran through most of my
undergraduate and even into part of my
my graduate studies and career jean-paul
Sartre is a very important 20th century
French philosopher one of the key
figures in existentialism and I found in
his his philosophy and also in his
literary works and some of his other
engagements kind of a model for running
my own life in structuring my whole life
and it was an unsatisfactory model for
me and so I ended up abandoning it I've
retained some elements of it that some
things about starts views that I do like
and I think that he still is a great
philosopher it's just I'm no longer and
have not been for him a very long time
in Sartre
so I got introduced to him first as an
undergraduate I know a little bit about
existentialism beforehand through
figures like Kierkegaard and Nietzsche
and I can't say that I understood them
all that well I'd read a little bit
about him some references to him when I
was in the Army before I actually went
to college I'd gotten myself a book you
know one of us or like different
philosophical systems I don't even
remember what it was called but it was I
think it was already round problems and
orientations towards things and I didn't
really understand what it was talking
about with with existentialism as far as
art went but then I got into an intro
class and I got introduced to Descartes
who I liked quite a bit but I also got
introduced to start and then in the
ethics class we we also studied Sartre
and I started thinking more and more
about it then when when I started doing
what we called contemporary philosophy
at our school I had a very idiosyncratic
undergraduate philosophical education
I'll talk about that in a moment
Sartre was front and center in the
contemporary philosophy class and so I
start reading more and more of his stuff
and I started really liking what I was
getting into and it kind of fit with the
lifestyle that I was living and the
relationships that I had and my
experiences and helped me kind of chart
out where I was where I was going to go
and how to think about where I was going
to go so my college education where I
went to undergrad and I hope and pray
it's no longer like this there was
Lakeland College the closest city is
Sheboygan Wisconsin it was actually out
in Howard's Grove Wisconsin and in a
very small philosophy department both of
the members they had the same kind of
view there was analytic philosophy then
all they actually knew other sort of
alternative things was was processed
philosophy you know they knew about
pragmatism but they thought that was
kind of dead and then there was
existentialism and continental
philosophy for them that existentialism
because they were they were you know
they were formed back in the 60s and I
don't think that they had read a lot of
additional thing since then so they
liked people like Sartre and Camus and
they really liked hillock theistic
existentialist Gabrielle Marcel to a
certain extent Nietzsche and Kierkegaard
yeah Spurs people like that they didn't
teach much Heidegger I think they didn't
really appreciate him very much
but they did they did like Sartre so
even though both of them were theists
and Sartre is an avowed atheist who
thinks theists are just you know in bad
faith and getting things fundamentally
wrong they they [ __ ] arch and they
thought that he was somebody to take
seriously and I was my education you
know I had my classwork
but for the most part I was just sort of
left to my own devices read what you
like and write something about it and so
on so I often did that and I ended up
taking that contemporary philosophy
class which largely focused on an
existential ism and actually we read
some interesting figures who you
wouldn't ordinarily get
like for example or take a you got set
you know unless you take existential
some really seriously you're probably
not going to read that guy
so Sartre resonated for me and then
later on I ended up actually as my sort
of independent study just focusing on
Sartre for an entire semester reading
and everything that I could get my hands
on that I could understand like the guy
I'll admit I didn't I didn't understand
quite a few things perhaps I still don't
now and I think that one of the things I
really liked about Sartre was that he
didn't just write philosophy he did
write you know big thick massive head
crack or text like like being in
nothingness but he also wrote more
popular essays and then he wrote novels
and short stories and plays so he was he
was engaged and I at that time I wanted
to be a writer and so I admired him in
part because he was you know he was
doing things all across the board not
always great I mean his his stuff tends
to be a little formulaic but he actually
is pretty good as a novelist when it
comes to safe descriptions of things
he's a good phenomenologist on that one
that's part of what made him you know
such such a great writer when I came to
works like nausea or you know the wall
things that I've shot videos now you
know if you want you can take a look at
my existentialism series that's ongoing
and so that's that's part of what
attracted me to him there was also the
fact that you know he was felt to be
really of the age you know addressing
the modern condition and I think that
one of the reasons why exit sign
ilysm particularly people like Sartre is
always going to need to be taught and
thought about is that well there are
some some things that you do have to
actually like be a bit older to
understand I think there's something in
the young person I don't want to say
adolescent but even into your 20s the
figuring out who you are how you're
going to run your life if you're a
thinking person if you're not just a
well I'll just kind of fit into things
or fall into things or things will work
out for me but if you're if you're a
thinker there's certain themes and
existentialism that for the the late
modern person are gonna make a lot of
sense maybe not to stick with forever
but the things that you ought to think
about infinite and pass through you know
for example am I getting my my values
ultimately just from sort of taking them
on other people say so or do I have a
role actually in deciding that this
matters to me and this rule is something
for me to to make part of my moral
system am I responsible for that sort of
thing yeah you know questions like am I
really free how how am I free what am i
I can't totally change myself I can't
totally remake Who I am what degree of
freedom do I have these sort of themes
you know what are human relationships
what how they be run you know am I am i
living and self-deception is that person
over there living in self-deception I
think that there's something that that's
something a whole bunch of things that
when you're an when you're an adolescent
and when you're a young adult then
you're a thinker these things are gonna
keep coming up for you and I think
existentialist philosophy is a good way
to try to get it get a grip on it get
your get your claws into it in ways that
other philosophical approaches may not
really help you with much because these
people thought about these issues as
well so my my first real foray into
Sartre I think was through first reading
centralism as a humanism and then
sitting down and trying to read nausea
the first time I read it I didn't I
didn't fully understand what was going
on I got some parts but I didn't quite
make sense out of all of it and then I
started reading more and more and
eventually I decided well I need to read
being in nothingness this is the work
that everybody says is the central work
of sorry
so I buckled down and this is about
sophomore year in college so I was about
22 23 years old and I remember being
struck by how how profound it was how
systemic how he was dealing with
fundamental metaphysical and yet
personal issues and I found that breadth
of thought really exhilarating and and
it was tough I was trying to you know
you when you're reading a text like that
you're trying to follow along where the
author's going and sometimes you're like
where are you going with that I have no
idea and then there were also references
to things that I didn't really
understand like you know at the
beginning he talks about different views
of nothingness and he talks about
Heidegger well I hadn't read Heidegger
and Lex about baritone and had a very
dim idea of what barracks old was
talking about he talked about Hegel and
I hadn't read Hegel at that point either
but I was able to make sense out of a
good good portion of it and what I read
I I found myself really responding to
and saying yeah that that makes sense
that that sounds right and it's
interesting because what was going on at
the time I was I was kind of I can't
have a bifurcated mental or intellectual
development going on because at the on
the one hand I was also reading some
things in the analytic philosophy like
Vidkun Stein in particular and some of
the the conceptual analysis stuff and I
was very much because I was also a math
major
at the time I was very much into the
foundations of mathematics and of logic
and I was doing a lot of work in you
know those sorts of things and the
promise there was that you'd have some
kind of form Eliza ballista in which
everything could find its place and
which you could manipulate to produce
the right results and make sense of
things I was really searching after
intelligibility on the other hand what
existentialism put forth particularly
through Sartre for me was something that
was really missing in that project over
there the I'll call it a low justice
project that that comes in part out of
Descartes and enliven its and people
like that who still had a metaphysical
point of view and eventually finds its
way into to the failure of the project
and people like Russell and Whitehead
but I was still kind of proceeding with
with portions of it and think again this
is this is really getting me towards
something but then I could see well when
it comes to like personal relationships
or figuring out like Who am I and what
am I doing here
dance stuff was really clear and and fun
and challenging but it was marked by a
certain kind of triviality and there was
a depth there that I found at least at
first in in Sartre and in the questions
that he was posing and the way that he
was going about them he wasn't just
trying to you know dissolve them you
know let the fly out of the fly bottle
he was saying no he was some real stuff
then we got to think this through
so I so I you know going back to being a
nothingness I think probably the stuff
that really stuck with me the most was
the discussions of the gaze and the
difference between in itself and the for
it's often the fact that the for itself
which is what human consciousness and
human being is is always you know in
danger of like trying to slip itself
into the in itself there's this demand
to objectify our existence but we have
to resist that demand again you know mix
makes good sense when you're when you're
trying to figure out who you are and
what you're going to be doing the way I
liked the the stuff that was going on in
in the plays and in the the novels I
started to actually pick up my first bit
of discussed with Sartre I have to admit
when reading the age of reason because
it started to become clear to me that
there were all these characters and the
one who was the the college professor in
it is really sort of a stand-in for
Sartre and he's kind of a a jerk when it
comes down to it and kind of willing to
leave things that he really ought to be
responsible for if he was a stand-up guy
to to other people to take care of but
that that comes later so what was it
that really attracted me to Sartre and
the Sartre in point of view what did I
sort of live in for a long time well you
know one of the key themes is that we
are we are condemned to be free and that
made perfect sense to me because I I
lived that and that that you know I saw
that all around me people who were
saying oh no I don't have a choice when
really they do have a choice I I just
have to be this way you know you know
and I look at there might be like you
you actually can be different you're
choosing this point of view that you're
in I saw a lot of people evading
responsibilities I saw that in myself at
times and there's one thing that's
really good about sorry you know he does
not allow people to evade responsibility
who he holds people's feet to the fire
perhaps too much in some circumstances
but he is stressed over and over again
you have choices you have it maybe use
this tiny little sliver maybe nature and
nurture is all over here maybe the
situation that you're in is all over
here but you have this tiny little
sliver and you are responsible for
what'd you do with that if you throw
that away and say oh I couldn't do
otherwise you were in a way betraying
what it means to be a fully human being
you're reducing yourself to a to an
object to something that's a merely the
subject of a play of forces and so that
was really important for me another
thing was that that's art this very
characteristic of his philosophy you can
see it in his insistence that that
psychoanalysis has to be rethought out
and his you know rejection of the notion
of an unconscious force art we're aiming
at being conscious of who we are the
decisions that we make the choices the
the situations all these sorts of things
the implications of them the full range
of the possibilities and that's why
that's partly why we're in anguish from
a Sartre in perspective we want to
become as fully conscious of who we are
and we want to dwell on the conscious
part not make excuses by by saying well
you know I just didn't know or things
like that Sartre would often quite quite
often would say things like well you
know why you didn't know because you
chose not to pay attention and that's
why you don't actually know and that's
why you made that decision based in
ignorance and again I am I am a person
who who is quite reflective and at that
time I was willing to call hyper
reflective I would actually say that I'm
better off now because I can turn the
thinking off back then I had a very
difficult time sort of turning off the
the mind and that doesn't mean that I
had like a bifurcation between my my
intellect and my emotions I was figuring
motional - and these things were kind of
fused together and often at odds with
each other but it meant that I was
always sort of you know thinking about
well what about this and what's going on
here and doing some analysis here and
you know
what kind of model am i working with and
Sartre he's he's that way as well
another thing that attracted me to his
thought was this notion of bad faith and
I do think that this corresponds to
something within adolescence and within
being a young adult of to use a very old
bird that you know like for instance is
used in The Catcher in the Rye
there are all a bunch of phonies out
there and it's you know it's pretty easy
to have that position when you don't
have a lot of responsibility and when
you're living an existence that is is
fairly poor but you're you're able to
have a good time when you want to and
you don't have a lot of physical
problems to be concerned with and you
don't have you know kids you know or or
people responsible for you know for what
you're producing at work that you're
accountable to and who are accountable
to you and you know projects like that I
think I think there's something that
makes a lot of a lot of sense with that
and so you look at other people and and
starts analysis of bad faith where
people say well I'm just this well I'm
just that I'm just hideous as the
example of just a waiter or he talks
about the woman who knows that she's
going to allow herself to be seduced and
ignores the hand that the other guy has
placed on her hand and where things are
going he talks about that as being in
bad faith and this is tied in with like
you know being aware of things being
conscious and also realizing that we
make choices also you know one thing
that that starts stressed was when we
make a choice for ourselves we're not
just choosing for ourselves we're
choosing the model of what a human being
ought to be
like so we bear responsibility by the
the fact of being human so these were
these were key themes that I kept on
thinking out and working out and you
know you also had other things too like
you know we try to objectify each other
you know he drew on the Galleon
master-slave dialectic to say that love
is always you know a desire to be
desired by the other and in some way to
dominate the other end and I always I
didn't really like that part about sorry
I was like I hope there's there's more
to it than that but I found quite a few
relationships that actually did kind of
seem like that and so that that
solidified it a bit and I retained my
interest in Sartre I remember for
example here's kind of a nice vignette
for you I I worked this third shift
security job at a hundred East Wisconsin
this giant skyscraper in Milwaukee and
it was it was totally dead downtown
except for you know a few bums and you
know the occasional prostitutes and you
know then the patrons you know from the
pub in the basement who would get out of
there and sometimes a few people working
late at night in these this giant
high-rise so you're you're alone with
the other guy who's often walking around
or maybe been sleeping on the job and
you have a lot of time to do reading and
writing and I used it actually for
working on my my German and for
translating bold layer from French into
English and actually trying to learn
some Chinese proverbs going to study
Mandarin at the time but I also used it
for studying Sartre and I reread Being
and Nothingness
over that that nine months that
working you know in the middle of the
night like totally by myself
and thinking it through thinking it
through and I found it made sense
another incident I'll tell you about to
this is Vera towards the end of what I
would call my Sartre in phase it was in
graduate school and I actually scared
off another graduate student who's who
was considering going to SIU and he and
I were you know we'd met and then we got
into this big argument the library he
was taking this kind of Marxist position
about you know people who are poor and
you know whether in this society they
are responsible for their poverty or not
now Sartre you know was himself a
Marxist but it was a very interesting
kind of Marxist and class was more of an
impediment in the France of his time
than it than it is in our time and my
position that I took and I just kept
battering this this guy down was look
there are choices involved if you're
gonna say these people are like totally
subject to forces that are beyond their
control and they couldn't possibly pick
a different path even when they're
provided with you know all sorts of
resources and a safety net if you're
gonna say that you're treating them as
less than human as having no inherent
dignity the dignity of a human being is
to be it for Sartre is to be able to
choose for better or for worse to make
ourselves into what we're going to be
and Sartre would say I think in in
modern late modern society in in the
liberal democracies that a lot of people
are in some respect responsible for the
condition that they're in if you're in
deep debt I think Sartre would actually
hold you accountable for that and I went
back and forth with this guy he almost
ended up in tears because he was very
committed to this kind of what I call
Neiman Marcus positions kind of
that we had in philosophy of these rich
kids who go to a school they learn about
Marx and now they're all about serving
the poor but they never actually saw a
poor person in their life or spent any
real time with them and saw how choices
really work themselves out so if they're
at a distance it's easy to see them all
as victims of those bad people over
there who are doing it and not to see
that you know if you choose to drink
every every night probably you're gonna
have some bad outcomes you know and if
you don't read to your kids and that's
your choice and you just watch the tube
instead and tell them to shut up when
they're reading those kids are probably
gonna you know be set back and you know
these sorts of things anyway the guy
actually was so upset and I think maybe
other things played a part of this that
you didn't come back I felt very bad
about that because I used to have a
problem with arguing that way now how
did I end up like leaving sorry well
there are some flaws with sart's
position you know one of the things that
don't like about it is that on some
level it turns us all into being you
know deep in our heart a bunch of
bastards and hypocrites that you know
can just make ourselves do something
other than that and and you know I think
that's true for some people but I don't
think that that works across across the
board I think that you know somebody who
is living is a saintly existence is not
simply in bad faith and denying who they
are especially if they were doing it
from you know some sort of religious
belief and interaction with with with
the divine
I mean Sartre totally rules that out his
views on love and relations between the
sexes are pretty pessimistic and like I
said sometimes fit our experience but if
that's all there is
boy that that's that's pretty damn this
notion of like everything has to be
conscious well maybe not
maybe maybe it really doesn't have to be
maybe we're not doing something wrong by
not bringing everything
just us maybe we do need some things
that are kind of working below the
surface maybe the unconscious does exist
and that I found myself you know with
time when it comes to existentialist I
found myself preferring other thinkers
who emphasized other themes in
particular Albert Camus I found a much
more robust notion of human solidarity
and even the possibility of love and
friendship in Camus than I did I did in
Sartre de Beauvoir ended up as Simone de
Beauvoir starts starts you know on-again
off-again I guess you'd say
friends-with-benefits these days right
she ended up completing his ethics
something that he never did with the
ethics of ambiguity and then she wrote
you know the second sex and all this
stuff and she pointed out some of the
problems with his views on women and
gender relations as well
I liked Gabrielle Marcel more to a
theistic existentialist actually a
convert in his own time because he has
this notion of mystery which
incorporates human choice and reflection
but has opening for that which would
would actually transcend us in our
condition and put everything into
perspective I also started you know
reading a lot of other continental
figures and I could talk about this this
other you know phase that I went through
who were very critical of sorry Sartre
was such a big guy in the mid 20th
century in France that you know in a
large respect he was the guide to knock
down when it came to later Young Turks
on the philosophical scene people like
you know
Foucault and a little bit earlier levy
nos and Toulouse and people like that
they they reacted against sergeant
against like the Stachel ISM of a they
thought it was too individualistic and
and left out too many important aspects
of human existence I know if you if
you've watched my videos oh sorry I
really do enjoy teaching and reading
Sartre and thinking three and uncertain
things I think he's fundamentally wrong
on some things but I I acknowledge that
he's a a great philosopher I think he's
at least of the second rank perhaps of
the the first rank where you'd place
people like Plato and Aristotle and
Thomas Aquinas and Hegel and Nietzsche
and Kierkegaard people like that so I'm
going to keep on you know studying him
throughout my life and I could end up
being attracted back to him again but I
really doubt it there it was a great
thing to pass through it was it was it
was wonderful to have Sartre there at
the right time in my life to think
through a lot of problems that I was I
was trying to make a sense of in a quite
disordered and discordant life that I
was living but ultimately I ended up
having to leave it behind